we'll get started in a couple of minutes
with the final subcommittee members on
her on her way upstairs so
important
I don't know
good morning I guess we'll start our
first subcommittee meeting
um of the morning uh this subcommittee
um is charged with uh looking at two
bills uh the first is HB 267 which is
relative to criminal record checks in
school employment that will be followed
by HB 628
dealing with accepting public funds and
background checks
so uh
this subcommittee
members include myself representative
cordiello and uh Noble Cornell Tanner
and Ellison but we don't have Cornell
and Ellison and instead we have oh I'm
sorry
I couldn't see I couldn't see with the
the light behind you so we do have
Cornell and Tanner
um and uh representative luno
so um this
this bill
was retained on a 10 to 10
vote
earlier this year
the request originating in Goffstown
to allow additional background checks to
be done on a periodic basis
and
um
uh I guess open it up for discussion
first if uh anyone wants to comment on
um
their recollection of the hearings and
uh the focus of the bill
if anyone want to start the uh
conversations and I see we also have the
uh Prime sponsor here
representative Tanner thank you thank
you um I I understand
um and sympathize with the discussion
that came in the hearing where some
people had not had back criminal history
checks for 10 years or so
um
but I also think that this is kind of
too loosey-goosey that um
that they may choose to require a
criminal history records check in any
group of employees on a more frequent
occurring basis I think that
that whole statement needs to be
tightened up to be more prescriptive
than it is right now
um I I just can't support it the way it
is
anyone else to represent Luna sure thank
okay
okay so I wouldn't so you're saying it
shouldn't include a whole group of
so
yeah I I rather than a group of
employees which is sort of uh
um
uh I I think a squishy type of type
thing like I I don't know what that
group would be you know
um and um and do it on a do it on a
basis that and that you know this
employee has had not been subject to a
criminal background check when they were
hired and maybe it's that
um uh maybe that's the standard I don't
know
foreign
I like the fact that it's a group that
sort of maintains the anonymity it's not
necessarily for someone who hasn't had
one but to more frequently do it and
overall this is just a permissive kind
of Bill it allows you to do it it's not
requiring anything so
um
as it's worded I don't have
May May the employee the employing
school administrative Unit School May 2
may choose to require May that word may
instead of must require would I so
that's just my take on it so that's why
isn't this something that could be more
a local control that if a if a district
or it's a school department wants to
negotiate it with their employees they
could put it into negotiations that they
may require
my recollection is that it might require
something in statute to to allow that
also to enable that
um representative Noble anything
uh
off the top I mean from what I remember
the group was included so that no one
um representative Alexander would you be
willing to come up and uh refresh our
memories on some of the background and
the purpose of the legislation the
intent
thank you for having me the subcommittee
for the record my name is Joe Alexander
I represent Goffstown so just to refresh
the memory of what this what the intent
of this bill is
um
my superintendent was concerned that he
is not allowed to or
during contract negotiations at some
time he may want more frequent
background checks than the one in law
that's required I Believe by the doe
when you obtain a license and the doe is
here so all he wants to do is have
legislation that would allow him to
during contract negotiations with a
union any union doesn't matter who it is
allowed to put in to have more frequent
background checks than just the one that
they get so that was really the intent
of it there's no requirement he just
wants to have that ability to include it
in the negotiations
and that is also doe is here I believe
as well to uh give some information if
you want to you know what the background
checks would include and things like
and all what and also the idea was to
not single out any one employee so yeah
like after a contract negotiate like
after a union contracts approved maybe
everybody goes and gets background
checks that we're not singling out any
one teacher because that's not what we
want to do sorry so that was the purpose
of adding group
and I think representative Luna I think
you you have a good point is that you
know you can put put a year on it if you
want I mean that that we just want the
intent of being able to have that
um Miss Fenton from the Department of um
so for the record my name is Diana
Fenton I'm with the Department of
Education but um I was also asked by the
department of safety to fill in for them
because they're all at a conference this
week
um I usually hesitate to speak on behalf
of the Department of Safety but I'm
willing to do it today but the caveat is
I if I give any misinformation I
apologize ahead of time I also asked the
department of safety if I since I was
speaking on their behalf if I could have
a hat and a badge and a cruiser and I
was denied so I would just like to put
not even that I didn't even get the Hat
nothing so
um
as the previous testimony was uh this is
not a bill brought on behalf of the
Department of Education we are aware of
it and I worked with the superintendent
from Goffstown
my understanding of his thought process
was just
the ability to negotiate with the Union
to have some sort of routine background
check
the reason it has to be in statute is
because the FBI requires statutory
language in order to disseminate the
record to a school district
so that's the reason that it would have
to be in law and I I have anecdotally
over the years I've had superintendents
truly a handful no more than five
expressed to me the concern of you know
someone's employed in the school
district they are subject to one
background check and then that's it and
I would like the ability to do that on a
more routine frequent basis that's not a
Department of Education issue that's an
employment issue and that's kind of the
the reason it is before you I do recall
last year looking at the language
and representative luno to your point
my concern looking at the language was
that this not become a weapon
that a superintendent can use to Target
one individual
I think in looking at the language it's
important to just make it applicable on
a on a consistent basis pick a number
three years five years ten years that's
that's up to this committee to decide
that it is applicable across the board
to a group
my concern in looking at the language
would just be that it could be used to
Target a certain individual which
certainly I think would go against the
intent of the underlying bill and the
intent of of this committee so I just
put that up there as as kind of food for
thought if you will
um and I'm happy to answer any questions
thanks very much Mr chair thanks very
much Miss Fenton
um yeah and and good point I and I and I
just to sort of clarify my my earlier
thoughts I wasn't thinking
um necessarily specific individual but
specific individuals that
have not had a criminal background check
in a certain number of years so rather
than all teachers or all support staff
or
all select group that you know that that
has some other you know identifying
factor that the identifying factor or
the qualifying Factor would be have not
completed a criminal background check in
the last 10 years 20 years 30 years
whatever that um that that
qualifying Factor uh is uh but uh
question is what what are other states
doing with respect to this um
um type of situation
it's hard for me to represent all states
I think that in New Hampshire the focus
was always heavily on employment the
background check historically was a
function of employment now is this
committee is well aware that is the
function that is shared with the
Department of Education upon licensure
um I think with Most states it is
divided there is the background check
upon licensure and then there is that
employment piece as well
um
I think historically because we've had
so many changes in this area of the law
I mean RSA 189 13A was dormant for many
many years it was dormant and this
committee has undertaken a lot of time
in looking at it understanding it I know
representative Tanner has put a lot of
effort into that Statute in particular
and really trying to identify the weak
areas
I think what this bill does and I don't
think the language is quite there yet I
think there are some really big concerns
with the language but the idea behind it
is empowering superintendents to have
that conversation with the Union to say
what is appropriate what does this look
like can we you know come to terms and
maybe one of the provisions is that
for individuals who did not have a
background check upon employment
and I think we can all agree that is
concerning
they would be subject to it
and then you build in another provision
which allows superintendents to have a
conversation with the Union to say what
does this look like can we come up with
terms of three years five years
something something like that
um
I'm happy to look at what other states
are doing in this area but I think
you're going to find that it is a split
it is a balance between credentialing or
licensure
yes
so thanks Mr Mr chairs thank you very
much John
um
so um
and I and I appreciate the the
clarification you've made with between
employment and credentialing and that
this section is is related to employment
not absolutely not not credentialing
um and and but I want to I want to
direct a question to your comment about
the the language and um and I was
wondering if you could
help interpret
um
the the the language that's in in there
may choose to require
the that part may choose to require
um on any group
um
School District to to put that
requirement in a into a collective
bargaining agreement during negotiation
or it would enable a school district to
require criminal back criminal history
checks may choose to require criminal
history checks any group of employees
um uh outside of uh the collective
bargaining agreement outside of the
terms agreed to in a collective
I think the bill as written is is too
generalized
my concern as I expressed earlier is
that it would be misapplied throughout
the state and you need to have that
consistency it has to be a little bit
more explicit
as to what this legislature's intent is
so if the intent is to allow
superintendents to enter into
negotiations
to allow for more frequent background
checks then I think that's what needs to
be stated I think you have to have two
Provisions one that says if it is the
consensus of this committee the concern
to address individuals who were not
subject to a background check upon
employment that's concerning I think we
can all agree to that that might be one
provision
and then the second provision and that's
I think few and far individuals right
this is going back a certain number of
years this is not thousands and
thousands of people
maybe hundreds
but a lot of people are going into
retirement so we can address that
concern and then there's a different
subsection that talks about allowing a
superintendent again employment
explicitly employment nothing to do with
the Department
having the superintendent have the
ability to enter into a negotiation with
a union to discuss
if background checks will be done on a
more frequent basis and put some time
frames in there right
three years five years ten years you can
give some structure to that
that will allow the dissemination of the
record from the Department of Safety to
the school district so you take care of
that piece of it and then you allow that
local control piece
as written I think this language is
concerning
that being said I'm sure there's someone
out there on the YouTube feed that is
saying to me yes but miss Fenton you
wrote it and that's probably true as
well and there are times where I look
back at my work and go well that's not
very good as I've said to my boss when
he doesn't like my work I'm not a robot
Frank sometimes I write bad things so I
think I did help with this language
honestly as I sit here today the
language concerns me I don't think it's
ready for prime time as this committee
has said
and I think my biggest concern is if you
give generic General language you get
inconsistent results throughout the
state
and that's what we see at the department
level and that is hard to get ahead of
and it's hard to claw that back
so I'm happy to to I mean obviously this
committee is more than just
representative luno but I'm happy to try
to try to craft some language which
would address the concerns
could I could I ask
um
you mentioned the changes to the statute
over the past few years and I think one
of those uh changes if I'm not mistaken
was
um to allow
um looking and I'm not sure if that
covers the employment or the
credentialing side of things to look at
um offenses maybe where there was uh not
a conviction yes but
um and also a look at um uh maybe uh
um uh convictions that were pleaded down
um to misdemeanor levels
many employees I'm sure had a background
check prior to those changes so I would
see maybe those circumstances also being
changed or incorporated into this so
that any new check was or checks could
be done
in line with the current statute
so that we pick up those
individuals who maybe have had a longer
employment history
um
as well your thoughts on that
yeah I I think that's a very valid point
to raise and I appreciate you reminding
me of it
um it is worth reminding this committee
that less than 10 years ago what was
released for employment purposes from
the Department of Safety was simply a
letter and the letter simply stated the
candidate and I will just use Glenn
cordelli as an example Glenn cordelli
applied to be a teacher at SAU 39
Mr cordelli does have a section 5
violation which is one of the
disqualifying offenses and cannot be
hired or he does not and he can be hired
but there was no information as to what
that offense might be or how long ago it
was or what
what it looked like I I really called
them the red light green light letter
because that what it that's what it was
it was the department of safety that
would call through an individual's
record and they would type out this
letter
there was a case in which a gentleman
was charged with very serious sexual
offenses felony level for whatever
reason they were pled down to
misdemeanors
he applied at a school district
Department of Safety typed out the
letter that said he does not have a
section 5 violation and he didn't
he didn't
he had some concerning things on his
record but he did not have a section 5
violation he was hired he reoffended and
that's what was brought to this
committee's attention
and that is what prompted the change in
the law to shift that responsibility
from the Department of Safety to the
district itself because it is the
district that has the liability give
that responsibility to the district and
release more information
so you are correct what was done 10 15
20 years ago is in stark contrast to the
procedure we have in place today and so
what might have to be put in there is
some language about grandfathering in
individuals
who might have some of those offenses
that
the depart the district
would look upon as troubling
I mean I I think that goes all the way
back there was a
I'm not sure if it was a study committee
or a commission chaired by Senator Ward
where we got into that that whole letter
with uh
um a number of different groups involved
in that and I I think that was really
the start of what has happened since
then in terms of tightening up the
background check process the criminal
records check process this committee has
put an enormous amount of time and
effort into that area and again
representative Tanner was did a lot of
work on that it's a difficult area
um and perhaps and I I throw this out
Simply as a suggestion
perhaps the
perhaps the permissive language of
allowing a superintendent to work with
the Union to say we're going to have a
background check every three years or
every five years and again I'm just
throwing out numbers
um that background check is just limited
which would prohibit employment anywhere
and that way you take away perhaps a bit
of that arbitrariness
that could could apply and again these
are just simply suggestions as we kind
of bat the ideas back and forth but you
want to put in some structure
if this committee were to allow this
bill to move forward
recognizing will be a different bill but
you want to have that structure in there
so that it doesn't get weaponized in the
field
thank you uh representative Tanner
I
I am having a couple of issues with this
one is that at one point in my career
from the dinosaur age to now I had
several background checks because when
we renewed our license with the State
Department of Education uh which was
every three or five years
um at one point a criminal
history checked was part of that that
requirement and it was done through the
Department of Education
with this bill I and you've mentioned it
too it could be hodgepodge across the
state number one number two
I also worked in with negotiations in my
own school district and I just can't
imagine negotiating criminal background
checks when they're required and when
they're not who's going to pay for them
who's not
um because it seems like the state
either has a compelling interest
to provide criminal history checks to
make sure that kids are safe as safe as
we can possibly make it in our schools
across the state uh very uniformly or
um you know rather than it be a a
semi-political football on a
negotiations thing
um and it seems like why should
Goffstown all of a sudden have every
five years
required Background Checks In
cure Sarge maybe 10 years and maybe you
know and if you switch schools if you
were to be hired by two schools where
where do you fit within that limit and
even though it is an employment issue
I'm sure at some point it would
um speak to credentialing if all of a
sudden they came up with a section five
uh that all of a sudden there would be a
flag down at the State Department of
Education as far as credentials are
concerned as well is that true
that is accurate yes and in fact the way
the law is currently written putting
aside this bill that's in in front of
you for your consideration my
understanding is that if if the
employing school district reviews an
individual's record upon employment and
they find a section 5 disqualifying
offense then yes they are required to
notify the Department of Education the
reason being is that the Department's
position is that the department does not
want to license or credential an
individual who is unemployable that that
doesn't support the field that doesn't
support
child safety so you are correct that the
law currently has written nothing to do
with this proposed Bill superintendents
have an obligation to notify the
department if there is an applicant with
a section 5 violation yes
um representative could I just ask you
if if you're
you're thinking along the lines that
um if we amend this with new language
that that language should specify
a required period for all school
districts to do follow-up background
checks outside of
the contract negotiation process
um
yes the I was not opposed to
getting background checks criminal
background history checks when you
renewed your license
um
the the big thing became the price of it
and the fact that particularly for a new
teacher that uh gets that early renewal
um it you know
just like us when we're
earning a hundred dollars a year you
know uh the cost of a computer or even a
tablet uh takes away from that so uh
considerably and teachers are
drastically underpaid so
um I would say that rather than leave it
up to negotiations and leave it up to
the superintendent
um if it in my opinion if it were going
to be
uh something that the state really
thought was important that definitely
um Representatives who knows piece that
if somebody is employed and has not had
a criminal history Tech
that is that is like a red flag I think
and and definitely I think we can all
agree to that but as far as the other
ones are concerned I think it's um
consistency across the state I don't
know how that goes with the Department
of Safety or whatever
you'd have to do an awful lot
uh chairman LED
thank you and while Diane and Sierra I
have a question for her but first it
appears to me in the 267 as written
could be used to Target rather and and
do it through as we might compare to the
kids misbehaving on the play yard you
line them all up against the wall or
just the one that needs to be lined up
against the wall that's causing the
issue so are we going to get around
dealing directly with an individual
by
putting forth legislation that
encompasses the whole state and all all
my my other uh issue is that there's if
it's a negotiated agreement issue and it
is negotiated that say every three years
or four years or two years whatever that
you put in it is the time in which an
employee criminal background check is
required but what about the new employee
that just came in the year before and
just had a criminal background check are
they going to have to have another one
the second year after employment if it's
not in conjunction we watch in the
timeline in the negotiating agreement
and who pays and who pays for this
that's going to have to be a local issue
and the last thing
um Diana is there any
is this a
is this issue
identified or is there a path towards
um dealing with uh the issue of why
you're having a criminal background
check through the code of ethics uh does
the code of ethics for example we know
there's a number of disciplinary steps
there and we've also recommended in the
past are discussed the possibility of a
fourth step that's initial before all
those other three steps and Brian's here
and he knows what I'm talking about
so and and lastly
um it says coming forth from the
administrators Association or is this
then just a singular administrator in
this state saying here I need this in
order to get things done
the way I like to do it in my district
so those are all questions but I'd like
to know is there any relationship
between the code of ethics and and does
the code of ethics uh if there's
something going on is that going to be
caught by the code of ethics and and
something can be done that Avenue with
an investigation
so under the code of of conduct under
the code of conduct if an individual is
arrested for one of those disqualifying
offenses they have an obligation to
and that's the only overlap on the
criminal records piece and the code of
um this again this bill was not brought
forward on behalf of the Department of
Education it was brought forward by the
Goffstown superintendent and just
anecdotally as I testified before I've
had a handful a very small number less
than five superintendents over the
course of my tenure at the Department of
Education just Express
a an interest in the ability to conduct
a background check on a more frequent
basis
um truly a small number of people I
don't want to over exaggerate that at
all but it is uh a discussion that that
is out there but this is not to my
understanding not brought on behalf of
the Superintendent's Association it was
just a superintendent from Goffstown
uh representative Miler I was wondering
if you had any um follow-up because I
think you were one of the first people
in the hearing to raise the subject of
excuse my sunglasses but I just had my
eyes dilated so I'm having a hard time
seeing and focusing at this point in
time I think the the issue of the
inconsistency
clearly the issue of negotiating this at
the local level is all has always been
there
and so my concern has been if we were to
negotiate this at the local level of the
the point that Ms Fenton mentioned the
inconsistency that would be across the
state I think would be a problem my
sense is particularly with the last
comment that the
Ms Fenton said this has not really been
that big of an issue other than within
this particular school district and So
based upon what the representative
laddin just said
I don't see any why we would pursue this
from a state standpoint and this should
be dealt with on an issue by issue basis
based upon whatever the behavior might
be of a particular employee particularly
dealing with the code of conduct and Etc
so that's that's kind of where I see
this thing going thank you
thank you
yes I I guess I just have a question
about cost
um and online four and five it says
applicant for employment in any position
so to me that is at any position as that
teachers Paris
cafeteria everything and if you're going
to require it are you requiring all
these people to pay for it themselves or
is the school district going to pay for
it because in Manchester if you're going
to require the school district to pay
for everybody to get uh
a criminal check every so many years
that's an awful lot of money with 2 000
Educators and then powers and then bus
drivers and cafeteria people and I'm not
going to vote for downshifting costs to
my school district for that amount of
money
or to to Paris who make 15 an hour to
have to get a criminal background track
um is there a general Sense on the
committee that
um
well I guess uh represent Miler even
raised it whether we need this
legislation or not or that's question
number one and two
um if we feel that something is needed
um do we want to work on some amending
language
and come back to review amending
I would just have one more question that
if
if a school district had found an
employee that had not had a criminal
background check uh without this without
this RSA would they be able to require
as a
part of their employment at that
particular time to get a criminal
background check
I don't believe they would the reason
being is that the law is clear that it's
upon employment and I think the second
layer to that is that the department of
not be able to disseminate the federal
record to the school district because
they have to follow
what the law says and the federal
background check can only be
disseminated to another governmental
entity in very limited circumstances
there has to be statutory language that
allows for that release I think so I
think it would be prohibited so so if if
I'm a superintendent and I'm hiring
uh let's say
um a custodial or cafeteria help that
sort of thing
um
and they have to get criminal background
checks
yes yes
so
um
if somebody their their employment their
terms of employment are yearly I would
assume uh they're they don't go under
contract under for example like a
teacher's contract that would be two
three years I would assume maybe I'm
assuming wrongly that a person that's
employed by a school district is on a
yearly basis so they are technically uh
they don't get paid over the summer so
their employment ends at the end of the
school year or July 1st when the school
year ends and then their employment
picks up in September so technically
they're re-employed
um
and at that point couldn't the
superintendent require that they take a
criminal background check rather than
write a law that
that requires it I mean isn't aren't
they hiring them and therefore as their
employer they could require the criminal
history
check I I will be honest with you
representative Tanner I am not involved
in those contract negotiations in any
way shape or form it falls completely
out of the purview of my job I know very
little about employment law I know two
things I like being employed and I don't
like when I'm not employed please
forgive the double negative
um I I really am not the person to speak
to when it comes to employment law
um
I I don't know what a staff person's
contract looks like I've never seen one
but it's not what the department gets
involved in
um I I don't believe that a custodian's
contract ends in June and picks up again
in September but honestly I really don't
know I've never heard of that I've never
received that inquiry from the field
um
I suppose that a superintendent could do
that to say well you're re-employed in
September and we're going to do a
background check I've never had that
fact pattern come before me I think
that particular fact pattern of an
individual who has been employed in the
district for 20 30 years prior to a
background check who was not subject
subject to a background check is a very
small
piece of the population it's an
important piece of the population and I
believe that this committee could could
address it and solve that issue but it
has to be very narrowly tailored to that
particular issue and I don't think the
issue is with a custodian or a cafeteria
worker the concern as expressed from
these the sponsor and the superintendent
who is behind this is that that very
small group of Educators who have been
in the field for a long time who just
were employed before the background
there's a little
so so I you know I think what
representative Tanner brings up is is is
an important
um point though that that
could actually have some bearing on the
laws it's written right now I'm also not
quite sure why it wouldn't apply to
custodians and other other employees
because
um
um we know that
students certainly get get get guidance
and support and it's not from you know
teachers but also you know Food Service
employees and custodians as well and it
should be applicable to them as well I
want to be clear that that is all
employment but I think the individual
who brought this law forward
his focus and again I don't want to
testify on his behalf but I think what
he expressed to this committee was his
concern was more about the the educator
who had been employed for that right so
not to say that it couldn't be right
right but going back to representative
Tanner's point on on that and and you
know again this is this is only you know
from school board experience not
um but you know I was chair for eight
years and I've signed a lot of contracts
and teacher contracts go year to year is
my understanding
um so it's almost like your
you're I mean yeah you're you're
certainly compounding the number of
years on there but it's a year to year
right um you know um
contract and and how
at least it wasn't our district and and
how does that
um
if I can sort of find it how does it
comport with the law comport with the
with the with the current law
um uh when it when it talks about with
the final offer of employment subject to
successfully completed Chris
um criminal history records check if
that offer of employment is indeed that
contract that begins July 1st
um and ends June 30th begins July 1st if
they hadn't completed a criminal
background check in their history of of
employment
um could that could the existing law
provide the language that's necessary
for a school board to say hey you know
what
um the you know these employees
were hired prior to the requirement
that's an interesting interpretation of
the law I don't think that's how
I only play one on TV
um I I think that it's an interesting
interpretation I don't think that's how
the field interprets it I'd be kind of
interested Brian
right
it had not been subject
understood understood again it's an
interesting interpretation I don't know
if the department of safety would feel
comfortable releasing the record based
upon that interpretation this is where
I'm limited as to how much I can speak
on behalf of the Department of Safety
I've never heard that interpretation
from the field as seeing it as kind of a
year to year now we have to run the
record again
amazing
correct
I again
I I'm here on behalf of Department of
Safety but not really
um I don't know if that would pass
muster for the Federal Regulations
correct
the Federal Regulations
they're kind of the Department of Safety
works at their behest right and they're
under very intense scrutiny from them
represent school districts starting to
have a number of employees which are on
stipend or coming in doing intramural
activities or through contracted
services with an agency of some kind
how would this change right here where
we put into a negotiated agreement for
example that every two three years we're
going to do this work with the
contracted employees
that are coming in those contracted
teachers through the agency
they would have to they would have to
address that in their contract
negotiations I I don't even know if it
would really affect those contractors
those kind of short-term contract
positions
so we're Contracting Services for
nursing in many school districts
absolutely contractors so this is for a
multitude of issues
so obviously within that contract the
school board the administrator is going
to say we want to make sure people come
in and have that criminal background
check yes however uh if we also have not
by uh negotiated agreement this issue
we're going to do it every two or three
years
is how do we ensure that that employee
that's coming or that person that's
employed by the contract and service is
I would think that that contracted
position would really fall outside of
the purview of what is before this
committee I think what is it before this
committee is
for those
full-time
long-term employees of the district and
the ability to negotiate with the Union
as to the opportunity to conduct a
background check on a more frequent
basis
and I think a school nurse coming in on
a contract for
a specified period of time would fall
outside of that
thank you
and further questions for Miss Fenton
yeah kind of for her and kind of a
comment so I
started teaching in 69 and I had to have
criminal background checks and I'm you
know up there in the years I can't
imagine that anybody's still teaching
that didn't get a required background
check in the first place
um because it never stopped I mean it
was required a little bit more often for
a while but then it never stopped
um so I I find it hard number one to
believe that there are teachers
within the school district who are
credentialed teachers
who have not had a criminal background
check okay number one and is that would
that be pretty
do you agree with that reasoning
these based on what you just said yes I
would agree with that I'm I myself am
not familiar with that amount of History
I can just talk to about the past 10
years or so
um but based on what you just presented
yes I would agree with you and the other
thing is that it seems like from our
discussion
that this bill is targeted only to those
people who have a negotiated contract
with the Union
um and from our discussion with uh
chairman lab about the contracted
Services outside talking about the
janitors or the
um you know cafeteria workers so really
the bill is targeted at people who are
under under uh negotiated contract and
in that case really you know putting
those two things together I feel as
though this bill is totally unnecessary
at this point
so
um thank you
quickly oh okay um
so I mean this was brought forth because
a superintendent felt the need for it I
I'm thinking that
you know it's likely it's not just that
this idea was brought forth there was
obviously someone in a leadership
position feeling some sort of need so I
I do see some purpose I always look for
that you know in legislation what is the
purpose now you you wrote this my
concern right now in voting for it is is
that there is a vagueness with this on a
more frequent
or recurring basis that that more
frequent like some sort of amending
language where it would ensure that it
wouldn't be you know weaponized or
targeting someone because more frequent
could mean every year you know you want
to have some sort of guard rails to it
so I'm thinking it's a good idea but
with some sort of amendment mending
language
I'm sort of getting the sense that
um we're going to need a second
subcommittee meeting
um getting sense there might be some new
language uh brought forward in terms of
an amendment
um uh but at the same time some feeling
that uh maybe
um uh the bill isn't required at all
um
would the committee uh be in agreement
that a second meeting is required
I I from what reptiana said if it
started when she started in 1969 that
means people would have been working now
for 54 years and I don't know how many
educators are still out there that have
been there for 54 years or more
um
so I I don't know that this is that we
need to do this you know and
for a handful of there could have been a
teacher in Goffstown that the
superintendent
thinks but has been there more than 54
years they never or they somehow slipped
by without getting their criminal check
but
you know it doesn't seem like it's could
it maybe have a straw poll just those
who do not think that this bill is
needed uh versus those who think that
um uh there should be some amending
language and that we should look at that
um that option
um how many at this point think that the
bill is not needed at all
yeah
and those that think there should be
some amending language and there is a
need
thank you
so I guess we're
funny about that isn't it
um well that's um since it is uh uh the
first motion in the house floor is
always a positive one so let's
um uh have a second meeting and we can
further discuss
um the need and maybe someone will bring
forth some uh um maybe we can work on
some amending language and we've had an
offer from uh Ms Fenton to to help in
that regard as well
and we find out the need for this bill
I mean can we actually maybe find it I I
we didn't
no okay
all right
so and and Mr chair in in addition to um
putting some
you know
putting together some some proposed new
language as as attorney Fenton has
suggested that that that you know you
know put some some you know time frames
on this like whether it's every five
years or every 10 years or has not been
conducted in 10 years so you know
wouldn't necessarily apply to every
employee if they had one conducted two
years ago when they were hired
um you know some some something
something like that but also to make
sure that
that this is a provision that could be
negotiated into a collective bargaining
agreement and not applied unilaterally
by the school board outside of a
collective bargaining agreement
I I think
um as discussed there could be uh two or
three
um
uh points uh to be made in an amendment
as to the negotiations as you just said
um you know I would just want to see you
know what that what that language you
know could look like the only criminal
backgrounds checked that can be
unilaterally applied by the school board
outside of uh uh collective bargaining
agreement uh is the initial
um application during the application
for hiring and that's obviously very
important because the the prospective
employee is not subject to a collective
bargaining uh uh agreement at that point
and that includes the superintendent on
on down so
okay
um so we will chairman Ladd I would
encourage this subcommittee to come out
with something other than a 3-3 vote on
this thing
um it's there are issues to been brought
up today we've had the department
indicate that the language as is stated
in this bill right now is not right
we need to get something corrected there
it appears to me that it is it targets
the way it is right now I'm also
concerned about a large District like a
Manchester might get into this business
what are those costs going to be for
every employee thrown on them or on the
individual so if it's on the individual
teachers we already have a teacher
shortage now we're going to just make it
a little more costly for these teachers
saying I don't want to get into this
business I have to take one the criminal
background check when I'm in school
become a teacher upon getting out of it
and going student teaching I have to
take it when I get employed and now I'm
going to have to have another one here
that we're starting to chop the money up
here and I think we've got to be very
cautious in that regard and I'd also
like to have the subcommittee do a
thorough check with the school
administrators Association find out is
this a bill that's supported by them is
it supported by the school boards
Association and let's let's get a handle
on this thing before we start change
teaching state law to maybe impact a few
that there are ways which we can still
deal with the few rather than having to
put another Statute in place
um
so can we
um not on a 3-3 basis but uh can we
agree on a subsequent meeting
um to further discuss this and possible
uh amendments that might be brought
forward
okay
so we'll we'll schedule another meeting
um I'll play into conjunction with some
of the other meetings that we have on
our calendar
um and we have one other bill that we
have to take a look at
which is
uh House Bill 628
um
requiring certain non-public schools or
education service providers that accept
public funds to perform background
checks on all employees and volunteers
um
this one also there was uh
um quite a bit of discussion and
testimony as I recall
um and a number of
issues raised again relating to
employment
um and who has actually covered
um under the proposed uh legislation
someone like to start the conversations
representative Tanner
um I'm the prime sponsor
um and when the bill was
um
offered uh I think one of the
things that that
came to me that I would like to work on
providing an amendment is that in no way
did I mean
or intend that a parent who homeschools
their child in their own home
would need to be
um
receive uh or do a criminal history
background check that was that was not
my intent and I would like to expressly
put that in the bill itself
um but on the other hand
um I do believe that we're making we
have to start making distinct
distinctions about children that are
actually being educated under the EFA
law and the student scholarship
organization receiving
taxpayer resource funding through State
funding
that it is a compelling interest of the
state
for the safety of children
that people dealing with those children
in a school setting
um be required to do criminal background
uh we had someone that came in from a
co-op that gave an example if if you
have six parents teaching in that Co-op
say there's 25 kids and just one of
those kids is getting an EFA
are you thinking that all they all need
to get background check now
if that Co-op
accepts EFA money as tuition
then yes they and and they do have
people hired or people that are
volunteers on a regular basis for the
children in that particular setting yes
I think so I mean it's it's
um
you know it's it's the compelling
interest of the state
I mean it's in in the interest of the
parents as well for them to be safe and
they're choosing to be part of that
Co-op
so I don't I don't see the issue of
needing a background check if there
they're choosing to be part of that
Co-op these are people that they Trust
there's trust and then verify
and I think that that's
you know I know people
um that I thought I knew
that
that we're not
um as trustworthy in the end that I
thought they were and
um to the detriment of children
so
thank you very much Mr chair yeah you
know that we we um you know parents make
decisions to send their their children
to
um to you know private daycare and um
and and you know my understanding is
that there's there's um certain
licensing requirements for licensed
daycare uh providers as well but and I'm
not at all equating
um uh homeschool education program to uh
to a licensed daycare I'm not equating
that at all but my question actually is
to representative Tanner
um in section five
um which modifies the EFA law are you
suggesting that um that all Amazon
employees uh also submit to criminal
I mean no no so all right so so um
because and and
um the reason I'm asking that is I think
the the term education service provider
is used broadly within 194 F to
organizations ranging from
home education programs
all the way to you know Amazon and
Walmart so
you know you know companies that are
providing materials right may I respond
to that sure so
my um thought on that
subparagraph five was that um it would
it was obviously Amazon and Walmart are
supplying Goods rather than services and
that but Prager University or prenda or
Kai actually provide services where an
individual is involved or several
individuals are involved or software is
involved that may collect data on
students
where there would be a need for a safety
net of some sort so so follow-up yes so
in order to line up with with with what
you just said and I agree with with what
you just said would
would
um
I don't know paragraph D in section five
have to have some
language to qualify which Education
Service what types of Education Service
Providers
um
would be would be would need to be
subject to
um uh criminal history records check
yes so we we need some yeah let's change
further uh discussion
um
point out that I think in some
regards this
legislation goes beyond what is required
in public schools especially in terms of
volunteers I think the statutes say
designated volunteers
um whereas this says basically all
volunteers so it goes beyond that we
require in public schools
and also in terms of Education Freedom
accounts the law currently says that
education service providers that accept
payments
um under the EFA statute are not an
agent of the state or federal government
so um I think we're
stepping into uh territory that we
shouldn't be in terms of putting those
restrictions on them and we've had
testimony going back to the
um that background check uh study
commission that I mentioned earlier
chaired by Senator Ward where we had the
non-public schools Council
um various
groups coming in and testifying that
they already do background checks
um it's uh pretty much required for them
in terms of insurance coverage that that
they do that
so I I
don't see a need for this legislation
and I I think
it goes beyond where we need to be
Russian cordiello
I do not see a need for this I also
think it may be harmful
um
it's somewhat related to a situation
that I deal with at the public library
where I work where
in order to just read a story it's story
time to be a guest reader you need to
have a criminal background check and I
think Echoes over the top and what it
does that I've seen and not just story
time there was also a man who was very
interested in helping children in a
chess club and I saw him just
leave the library I talked to him he
thought it was you know ridiculous that
he would have to have a criminal
background check to help kids with
playing chess when the parents are there
the the librarian's there and they still
so that's gone to an extreme at the
public libraries but I just that's my
background so I just wanted to bring it
up that I see how that discourages
volunteers from just coming to Story
Time and reading the story to the
children and so I see this could go in
that direction where it would discourage
volunteers there is also that issue of
of trust which representative Noble
brought up you know and again in my
current position I've met a lot of
homeschooling families in the town I
work in and um there is they know each
other they work together
um there's no need for this so um
where's the Tanner
um I maybe it's because I've I've had
criminal background checks when I've had
employment outside of schools inside of
schools volunteering for different
things substitute teaching uh driving a
bus
um that it's that I'm not insulted by
having a background check I I feel as
though if I have nothing to hide
there's no reason for me not to comply
with a background check and I also feel
that it is a safety net for kids I mean
we've had
kids that have just gone
into who knows where outer space we've
had numerous cases of kids that have
been abused that are found at home
um that
I think that we should recognize that
this is this is not an intrusion on
people this is a safety net for kids
and kids are
being taught by imprenda for example an
18 year old who has a CPR
certification and
may or may not be part of the community
um and and as I said before there have
been part of people that I know that
have been part of the community that
would be the last people I would suspect
would be involved with child abuse and
yet were
so
um
I just see this as as a compelling State
interest
you seem to be going back though into uh
um uh abuse at home or it seems like
you're going back toward the
homeschooling situation
no
I'm a little bit confused there's a
reference here to rsa189 13-a underneath
uh number four here on on the bill
and I'm looking at uh that statute right
now under 193 13A Roman One Part B a
non-public school may elect to require
criminal history records check
now where it says in law that they may
elect and through an alternative program
I can receive funds through my
savings account
and have my student go for a class let's
say at a private school for one period a
day and they're receiving instruction
but that private school that
non-public's not required to have that
criminal background check
so where are we here you know
um are we now getting the business we're
going to require the non-public schools
to have criminal background checks when
they you know I'm just curious where
represent little
yeah
um thanks thanks very much I don't want
to get get out over my skis here but I
think the section of the law that you
just referenced uh representative Ladd
um was in existence long before 194 F uh
came into being so now we're seeing a
situation in New Hampshire where
taxpayer dollars are used to pay tuition
bills for students that go to private
schools and I think as representative
Tanner pointed out there's a um what's
the the term a compelling State interest
in assuring the safety
of these kids when when at those private
institutions and um and and the state
did not have a a a financial interest
in it until 194 F came into being that
all said
um uh everybody in New Hampshire is a
mandatory reporter so so if another
um uh adult
you know at a non-public school uh
witnessed uh you know a tuition student
being abused I think they'd have an
obligation to any any
um
um any grown-up would have an obligation
to uh to report that but uh but yeah
this goes beyond it
um if um if um if you're a non-public
school taking State uh dollars uh now as
a result of 194 F than um then then you
would be subject to um to this new
um part in section five
um
paragraph d
I I would just
um uh say that uh I think courts uh up
to the Supreme Court have said that
um once those funds go into the account
of a private family they are no longer
public funds they are private funds at
that point
um and we just had a discussion
um on the previous bill
um about uh you know if we get into
compelling interest of the state
um wouldn't it be a compelling interest
uh to make sure that uh those employees
in a school district did have a
employment background check so I think
there's even more of a compelling
interest if we want to raise that
argument with the uh the previous bill
then then this bill
perhaps of tenor
first of all I think the this the
um
referral to the 193 13 was also to to
say the designated volunteer
um to indicate that's where the the
language about designated volunteer is
and I think that um you know schools do
uh the the reason we said the last bill
was probably unnecessary was that even
uh from the state department we heard
that it is a very very very very very
very rare circumstance where a person
who is a teacher
credentialed it would be a mistake if it
was a credentialed teacher that didn't
have a background check
um so I think that that and as far as
whether it's public money or not I think
that uh similar to the original uh
discussion of this bill which ended in a
10-10 decision that were on a a 3-3 uh
course on this one as well at this point
in my yeah
um so I think that
um
in
in that case
um we would just uh go to the full
committee
when we vote in probably November
correct chairman Ladd
um with the outcome of this subcommittee
being split vote as well
um I have two questions on that one is
that as I said there are a couple of
amendments I'd like to to do on this and
would would that be allowable at the
another subcommittee meeting
if you're you're coming back to do the
other bill as a subcommittee do it
during a subcommittee and air your
amendments there so then we go to the
final because we're going to be running
through 20 bills that day okay um so I I
advise you to do it as I think
representative was going to suggest okay
if you do want to uh offer an amendment
we will take that course then okay all
right
both
267 to 628 will come back for a
subsequent meeting to be scheduled in
the near future
um
yes right definitely yes yeah
um so we have another uh set of bills
scheduled for 10 30 uh House Bill 623
and Senate Bill 218 so we can uh maybe
take a five minute break until 10 30 and
foreign
maybe we'll uh get started with our next
uh subcommittee meeting I think most of
[Music]
um
I don't know um he I know he had other
okay
um members this is uh subcommittee
meeting on Two Bills uh the first we
will consider is um House Bill 623
establishing a teacher candidate loan
forgiveness program
um and I believe representative luno you
had an introduction so thank you very
much Mr chair uh and members of the the
subcommittee
um I I bring to you today a student
who's a senior at Bishop Brady High
School her name is Morgan Casey and uh
she's going to be
interning with the the education Dems
Republicans can do their own thing too
she's an ELO student uh with us an
informal ELO she has more credits than
uh than anybody could could you know
realistically amass towards uh towards
graduation but she's very and I and I
don't mean to you know disrespect any
any political side on this but but uh so
seriously all members of the committee
um uh I I hope will uh will will get a
chance to meet her and ask her questions
and if there's things that that you can
offer that she may be interest uh
interested in uh please um please don't
hesitate uh uh to engage Morgan she's um
uh like I said it's an informal ELO and
uh and she's really interested in in um
and yeah she moves into her college
career and afterwards to get involved
with public policy but let me just put
you over with Morgan yeah thank you
everyone for having me here today I'm
just excited to learn and see what these
meetings are all about
do you have any questions
um before we get started on uh the
process that we have before us today or
anything in general
um I don't have any questions right now
but if I have questions throughout the
process can I ask them during or should
I wait till after
um maybe we will have a break in between
the two bills so
um you know that would be a good time
okay thank you great great thank you
very much Mr chair
okay
um so
uh the majority
of
members of this submittee
um here uh representative uh Balboni
um Damon cascaden mileron Hall
um and myself and representative uh
Noble
um uh representative Ford McDonald and
Lakers do not appear to be here
Mr chair Balboni has been uh oh I'm
sorry spending time with her new
grandchild has come down with a cold so
she said she didn't think she should be
here great okay
get started on House Bill six 23
um and uh I believe
representative Miler you were the prime
sponsor of this do you want to kick off
the discussion well yeah this uh this
was brought forth
from conversations that we had with the
teacher shortage committee
and
um as we looked at a number of options
dealing with uh assisting
to engage
new teachers
in a way that would
um allow them to
deal with their loan structure that they
have in schools as they graduate
and this was one of the things uh the
the Senate if the Senate subcommittee
uh it's this loan option was an
alternative that we looked at
for assisting teachers who are beginning
as we know that the uh
those who are between uh
within the five-year period there is a
high rate of teachers who basically
leave the profession
and so this was an attempt to try to
deal with the issue of teacher shortage
Rick is on the committee with me to try
to deal with a way to help
teachers as they start their career and
in an attempt to try to provide some
loan forgiveness as incentives for them
to be there you'll note that there is an
amendment that was presented Amendment
uh zero two two one H that talks about
how the uh what the loan forgiveness
would be it would be up to twelve
thousand dollars uh Over a four-year
five-year period uh and uh so we would
hope that this might be able to be
initiated this program has taken place
in several other states I do not have
the number of states that have done
something like this but it has been a
very popular program particularly for
students for areas where there are
problems in attracting teachers in rural
areas Etc and underperforming schools
and so that's why Mr chair this was
presented in trying to uh to uh
represent the kinds of conversations
that we've had in the teacher shortage
committee
um thank you very much
I was wondering um
I uh brought the wrong folder and did
not have my original copy of this and
and the public hearing
um but could you go over the amendment
again because the amendment is not
listed on the uh Bill details uh screen
yeah the the amendment uh again tries to
focus it it
um
it illustrates uh the federal of the
loan uh several Federal long programs
that are available
and it targets a rural and
underperforming uh Educators at
underperforming school Educators as a
way to provide incentivizing
um and helping rural school districts
and underserved school districts and by
the way those are terms that are
familiar uh to the Department of
Education
and they're the definition of what they
are in on lines 23 and uh 25 and then it
basically goes over on the next page
that talks about
um how the teachers would basically be
reimbursed you know fifteen hundred
dollars of first year twenty five
hundred dollars a second year Etc
and so that's that's really what the
amendment is all about
thank you
further
yes representative cascad thank you uh
just some clarification questions on the
amendment it was
um written just a little different and I
I recognize the term my question is
because there's a federal teacher loan
forgiveness program a teacher's access
after they complete five years then
they're eligible to apply so would this
bill allow anyone within the first five
years to get loan repayment
I'm not sure
I'm not sure all right so the there is
um a Public service loan forgiveness
there is a teacher loan forgiveness
which again is has been quite popular
I've signed a lot of forms on that
teachers who have worked five years now
become eligible
to
um access that there's a Perkins loan
which is not as common and it's real
specific to math science El uh Ela
not Ela but ell
um
and then there's state-sponsored school
loan forgiveness programs that are
called Direct Loans
um so I'm wondering what group of people
are we missing I'm sure there are in
terms of loan forgiveness
and does this amendment
sort of ask them to stay for X number of
years yes yes yeah
the intent here is that once a teacher's
is in one of these defined schools that
they would stay there for that period of
time and I think the other intent is is
that as they uh become familiar with the
with the school district Etc that they
would even stay subsequent to that loan
forgiveness period come
so it's just a matter of defining
how early in their teaching career can
they access these right exactly loans
okay
um
and ask you a question representative
um uh sounds like you mentioned three or
four different programs and they are all
all except this state Direct Loans those
were Federal programs that you were
talking about
uh yes
yeah with those
um programs were they uh was there a an
amount uh
a specified do you do you recall
um in terms of the amount of forgiveness
it was uh the Providence loan was for
our um teachers at who were teaching
full-time at a low-income School in
certain subjects
um and the loan is a certain percentage
a year
um says if you're eligible for this
program up to 100 of the loan may be
canceled for teaching service in the
following Implement increments so you
have 15 percent gets canceled out in the
first first and second years of service
20 in the third and fourth
and 30 percent in the fifth
and each amount canceled
um per year includes the interest that
was accrued since Perkins Perkins I
believe their guidelines are a little
bit more stringent than say the
the teacher alone forgiveness that's the
one I'm the most common with a lot of
teachers after five years
apply for that
that the teacher alone forgiveness is 17
500 up to seventeen thousand up to
Seventeen five hundred yes
um
and sometimes it's five thousand it
fact who just asks representative Cass
Academy when you say what area do you
mean what subject area or what
geographic area or both uh it's a
combination of both uh in terms of the
um
Perkins loan must be a high low income
area
and
and subject area but the teacher
forgiveness is primarily in special ed
and secondary math and science
those three categories qualifies them
for 17 500 in forgiveness
and then eligible teachers qualify for
so it sounds like that student that is
graduating from college and just
starting out is the pool of people
probably should be targeted to to Access
Loans immediately because I mean when
they come out of college they get a new
job they're up on housing I mean they're
in the poor house
but I don't know if that was the intent
fault
thank you
um so two questions can we get a cop get
copies of the amendment I don't have it
either and I think it would be helpful
um and then related to that in the
original bill
I'm understanding it correctly
um
it speaks about starting with students
who have completed their sophomore year
in the University system so if that's
retained in the amendment is part of my
question
um
okay
it's uh it's uh two zero zero two two
foreign
awaiting copies of the amendment
um you have further questions of
discussion
um
well I'm I've got a question sure
because
um it says oh you'll see this on on the
second page it refers to this is the
amendment you're referencing yeah okay
it refers to a commission
and uh and for the life of me I'm not
representative Cascade
um just to add in part four of the
amendment it kind of identifies the
reimbursement of eligible education
expenses may be provided on behalf of a
rule and underperforming school educator
and one of the criteria is they have to
have signed a contract with such a
school
so if you've got a new grad again
if
you don't want to sign a contract for
five years
at the onset because then if they're not
a good teacher you can't not renew them
no I think I I think that would be
subject to any
performance appraisal of an interview I
mean so they probably should say that
somewhere that it says
has assigned contract
if performance evaluation is
satisfactory to the district
than that candidate
should
but at any time could be let go within
that five years
either with the risky part
okay with the amendment or the original
bill
they have an effective date on them
so
teachers who Maybe started out the year
before would not be eligible is that the
way the
the language is say that again if
um if
um if the loan forgiveness of program is
effective let's say July 1 uh 2024 right
someone who was hired in 2023 would not
be eligible for the loan forgiveness
program
good question yeah don't know
also I think too
a new employee is an at-will employee
until the fifth year
correct correct yes so I mean that would
fall under the same kind of Aegis
of that
yes yeah okay because they're not that
will but still subject to a one-year
teacher's contract but they they're not
afforded to process right exactly that's
well it's more it's it's right right
yeah right there's no no reason you
don't need to explain it in five years
but after that there has to be
right okay yeah so you're saying the at
Will is at any time
I'm using no it's any time up to five
years I'm using the app will the term
out will maybe it's the wrong term
that's more of a commercial okay um you
know it's non-public uh you know type of
thing where you can where you can you
can hire and release a work of a person
any at any time for any reason
um the collective bargaining you know
all teachers are subject to the
collective bargaining in the contract
yeah
um
how does the um
forgiveness work
um
foreign
um who covers the amount that is Pace
well I think the intent here was that it
would be a state program State program
right it looks like uh
on the last section
of the amendment
um
as I think you indicated has a an
appropriation
um for fiscal years 24-25 with a million
and two million dollars
and calls on
um a warrant to be uh issue to
arrive at that money from the from the
treasury right
what was that amount again please
um it was 1 million in 2020 a year
ending 2020 June 30th 2024 and 2 million
all right so if represent you go ahead
I was just reflecting on your inquiry
representative cordelli about I think
potentially saying who's paying
correctly if I'm not paraphrasing
accurately yes uh line 35 and going
forward from there in the amendment
speaks about the department reimbursing
public schools with the public schools
submitting to the department
verification
of eligible loan repayments and then the
department reimbursing the public school
for that cost
so
assume the department is the Department
and if I may sure
so relative to your question before we
I mean I would appreciate some
discussion about the question of making
it retroactive to at least some degree I
realized that
changes the costs
um
what the need is already there and so if
this
and right now the amendment says
effective July 1st 2023 which is
obviously not going to be the effective
date well
I don't know that would be retroactive
so I guess this is a question how would
retroactive work how would it be the
question I don't know that
in all the Appropriations are for
um
if I could ask representative Ladd in
terms of the teacher shortage
um
committee how does this fit in with
what's been going on with that committee
I I think this parallels a lot of the
discussion which we've had on the
teacher shortage committee
um
sometimes I look at the amendment here
and I don't think it's wide enough in
scope but we're talking about rule
locations or underperforming areas based
upon the nape I don't know if that's the
proper tool to use
uh but when we're talking about a area
like a Manchester which is in dire need
of of teachers in certain shortage areas
um so you know I I the whole concept
here I agree that we've got to do
something to keeping and attracting
folks into certain areas in the state
where we have shortages but I think we
have a shortages of special ed teachers
everywhere
not just you know in uh the Manchester
but you might have them out in the
wealthier property I hate these rich but
a well-endowed communities
so
um and of course we do know that the
shortages primarily they're in in
communities which can get the good
teachers from surrounding areas come in
because we pay more based on our
negotiated agreement
so I I concur with much what I see I'm
I'm reading this being trying to grab a
hold of it now for the you know probably
the second time or third time I'm just
trying to get a good fix on it
um
I I you know 20 enrolled students per
square mile
that's kind of a a general term we use
in a lot of language like this is New
Hampshire same as you know some others
uh Estates and and using the neighbor
grades four eight eleven you know we
also give our Statewide assessment here
we also have graduation rates too that
which we could use as a determiner
um but I I I support the scope of this I
I in the intent of the bill
um it needs and you just need a little
more time you need some work yeah but I
I think we can't delay too long on it
but uh I I think it needs work and I
think that would be the physician of
those that are on the teacher shortage
committee as well yeah
[Music]
we do have uh teacher shortage committee
coming up next Monday I think
and uh I I'm not sure they've even seen
this we've talked about the conics
admire that we bring this to that and
get it on the docket for discussion at
that meeting so we can go through it and
you can have another set of eyes looking
at including some Senate eyes yeah good
I think we'll do that I'll do that yeah
um and I think for retention retention I
think it would be a carrot for teachers
graduating from college
if the salary is not as high in one
District as another but yet there's an
opportunity for
for a loan repayment
I think that would be a good thing I
think it's that pool of people that are
struggling to stay in the field because
they can't afford it
um
and also language should be in there so
that it is up to The District in terms
of pending evaluation process you know
on this whole issue of teacher shortage
we've looked at this we've looked I'm
introducing a a mentoring bill that's
also uh for this session uh I also heard
the other day
um I was talking with representative
woodcock
and he was saying that he uh while he
was in Texas with his uh new grandbaby
he read a story of Houston schools the
school district is actually building
housing
for teachers a huge complex that they're
they're now developing to attract
teachers to come
to teach there and have you know reduce
housing costs for them so there are a
number of different things that are we
haven't we haven't gotten to the housing
issue here although there is a child
care is another issue although there is
uh we we did discover that in uh in
Littleton
uh that there is uh housing some you may
be familiar with that not very but I'm
aware there was a housing issue there
where they were providing housing for
for teachers and interns actually yes uh
to try to attract teachers because of
the rural nature of the particular
School District so this is just one of a
variety of different Alternatives that
we're looking at Glenn can I uh
interject for a second I'm also
concerned that
we're talking about I I believe the
university system of New Hampshire
we talked about University system in the
last line of the we also talked about
New Hampshire but
we're seeing fewer graduates coming out
of the Department of Education at UNH
than we have in previous years not just
because of demographic either
and and so we're picking up teachers
coming out of snoo we're teaching out a
teacher's coming out and we want to
retain these residents in our state
teaching our state and I'm not quite so
concerned whether they're a graduate of
King Plymouth or UNH
um I think we ought to be trying to
attract and keep our New Hampshire
students that are deciding B teachers in
our state regardless of where that
degree is from
we're employing more teachers in the
state now of course that are from out of
state institutions
than we are from our own in-state to as
institutions
to be really effective we need to
you know think of where is the well this
money is coming from but also
um trying to get more students
participating in this program
yes
thank you
um I Echo representative Ladd in regards
to looking at this more broadly than the
University Systems new Colby Sawyer
College any number of Institutions that
are
educating teachers a lot of them people
who are residents of New Hampshire who
grew up here and then they leave
to teach elsewhere this could make it
more attractive for people to stay
I'm also wondering if the
consideration of Rural and
underperforming what representative Ladd
was noting that you might be in a
non-rural area but
be an underperforming school and for
example need special educators
but if instead of it saying Rural and
underperforming it was rural or
underperforming and there's more than
one place where that distinction would
need to be made
so in other words a teacher would
qualify for loan forgiveness if they
were either in the rural District or the
underperforming district but it didn't
have to be both
representative thank you
um
I just I have a question on part eight
I want to make sure that I one number
um it would be line number 35 36
um it mentions that it will be the
department will reimburse the public
school for qualifying loan repayments
does that mean that the public school
district will be giving the money to the
teacher and the state will reimburse
them
so that means the public school has to
budget for that money ahead of time
and who knows what could happen I'm I'm
concerned about adding that dollar
amount
to a school budget that's lean
and could we skip that step completely
um
and applies to the state I I just don't
that's a that's a good point I don't
like coming I know what we did with dual
concurrent enrollment the money was
going to the district but now we send it
directly to community college system and
we take out that middle name yeah
it's good it's a good point get it off
yeah and it already has in Section 5
line 22
that the educators are applying to the
Department
for this program so why does the school
district even need to get involved
right other than verifying should be
good
um I think
one concern I have is uh the concept of
loan forgiveness and need in terms of
employment
um you know we've been having a lot of
conversations in my County about the
nursing shortage and how it's impacting
our County nursing home and the costs of
bringing in agency staff
and and you know articles all the time
about the nursing shortage
um so uh you know in other Industries
I've read about in the state as well
that are having shortages but we have
lowest unemployment rate uh you know in
in the country I think or one of the top
two
um so the whole subject of loan
forgiveness and you know where does it
start where does it end
representative Don along those lines I
had a question um drawing your attention
to page for a specifically lines nine
through eleven so towards the end
and the on the amending language and the
Amendment grants the governor the
ability to draw additional sums of money
from the treasury if necessary is that
power able to be checked by the
executive Council or is that power just
granted to the governor
I don't believe it goes through the
well this has been this has been good I
appreciate this let let's Rick and I
take this to the group next Monday
and give further feedback on that and
then I I made some notes Here I I have
got some questions that on this too so
um
uh let's we can set another meeting and
I'll bring back something
representative cordelli yeah um I I
um
also feel that we got to get a better
grip on understanding of where the
shortages may be
um
as you recall several years ago about a
year ago we were asking for information
from the districts in terms of what are
the superintendent over there we only
got 20 percent return we got a high
according to Mr Appleby right now I'll
up around 56 percent return so we're not
getting a good return from the field on
this information we need to make these
decisions
um we do know though the teacher
shortage committee does know that there
were shortages before covet
in certain subject areas
unlike the maybe in nursing as well but
I'll tell you right now according to
what I heard the higher education
meeting the other day with the trustees
is we're putting out enough nurses now
that we're in a little bit of an uptick
on it now it may not keep going like
that
but compared to where we are with the
teachers there is still this downtick
but I'd like to see some real good
information coming in from the districts
as to where these specific shortages are
in these teaching areas we knew
beforehand we had special ed background
issues we knew we had issues dealing
with the Sciences we couldn't find them
especially in the rural areas so
I'd encourage doe to try and get a
better return on the survey this year
and I know that I spoke with even Steve
just this weekend and they're trying to
work on that but we need to get that
information too for this teacher
shortage meeting which we're going to
have here in a week
representative Hall
thank you I'm wondering about uh let's
say on page two lines 27 to 29 what
about the teacher who's a great teacher
but has been faced with reduction in
force so they've been riffed in their
school district
does that mean that now they're not
going to be eligible if they go get a
job at a different school or a different
School District even though they were
they went to a rural or underperforming
school
but if they were ripped they had and
they're a great teacher
but you know what our numbers are down
and we don't need that science teacher
anymore so now they've got to go
yes the other piece to think about when
you do go to committee I'm finding in
the ads north of the notch is
Administrative positions I mean there
are assistant
administrative positions
um is I mean just look at the
superintendent level there's a ton of
interims but I'm finding that building
level administrators were not
traditionally on that critical shortage
list that came out but now you're seeing
that come up so if you've got somebody
who was in the field went back to school
and got certified they may have loans I
don't know if that's a pool of people
you wanna
add to this or not I mean I'm open to
either way but when you're talking about
critical shortage it's hard to get good
administrators to do the job
think this our study was primarily
before we had we yeah we had a number of
people who came to us nurses being one
Paris being another uh and I think the
committee said no no we we need to focus
just on teachers and that's that really
is the scope of it yeah
but according to the law a principal is
or the principal as a teacher
principal is a teacher
okay sorry
so I I think uh the consensus is that we
will have a follow-up meeting
um at some point soon after the teacher
shortage uh committee and get get their
uh input and possibly some many language
after that I appreciate the feedback
yeah thank you very much
uh yes representative Damon thank you
just one more could we ask the doe to
provide us some
um
maybe list of communities that
are rural by the definition here of what
is it less than 20 enrolled students per
square mile
um and similarly which ones are
considered underperforming
yep
um we can make that request to the
department yes see what we got yeah
thank you
so I think uh that will end
our time on uh House Bill 623
and we have uh ahead of us uh Senate
Bill uh 218. uh should we move right
into that or get out when we can yeah
uh Senate Bill 218 establishes an early
um
and can we have Brian Hawkins up here on
that one please uh I know Brian has
talked with Steve Appleby and I've
talked with not Steve but not on this
topic and he may have some information
on mentoring that he may want to hear
from the Department
sure
thank you Mr chairman for the record
Brian Hawkins from Nea New Hampshire uh
so I did reach out to Mr Appleby at the
department to see if he had any
suggestions uh to address some of the
concerns that the committee made back in
the spring and so
um
and I know he couldn't be here today so
uh because it it did sound like that he
may have some uh suggested language
um we did work with Senator Fenton on
this bill
um and the idea being that those early
years that an educator is in a school
are as the shortage committee also heard
ours are the the most critical and to
make sure that their um our plans in
place at the school district level and
then and then as well as uh you know
assistance for those school districts
that want to put in place a mentoring
plan
um and that was the idea behind the um
the grants
so I'm happy to answer further questions
of
um I know there was some question about
uh from the
routine discussion about who is an early
educator
um and and I guess I would point to the
the first three years that uh in um
Z1 line seven
um the idea behind this is the people
who are
early in their career in education
or it may be their first year in a new
school district
or or in a first year in a new role
because those are those are also very
important
times for an educator to have that
yes representative
it's my understanding that the title two
funds would also cover a mentoring
program title two yes title two can be
used for that okay
so I think I'm confused why this is even
needed if that's covered because from
what I understand
that money is not being spent down
and we would have to spend this state
money before we could even get into the
title II funds but so my recollection
from the hearing
um and again we there was uh no mention
of this in the Senate phase but my my
recollection from the hearing from the
Department was they were not sure as to
whether that was the case or not that
was presented to the committee
um but that that was going to be
confirmed and so um I'm probably not in
a position to you know uh say whether
that's true or not I would I'd point to
the folks who handled the title to
um but that was my recollection from
but
your recollection was that the uh State
Grant funds would have to be utilized
prior to title two kicking in
uh that from what I recall
um uh there was the concern raised by
the department was that any
um state or local funds had to be spent
down
um prior to accessing Title II funds but
that that was going to be followed up on
yes thank you for the clarification
thank you
representative cascadden thank you
um Yes again I think I raised the
question earlier about the term early
Educators
um my perception would be as a
certification of newborn to grade 3 or
preschool or Early Education and it
sounds like it's anyone that's new to
the profession
is that what it's intended for yeah I
think the thank you for the question the
intent being new to the sort of the uh
in in the requirement for the for the
local master plan to include uh a
professional development in the first
part of the bill the intent was the
definition of early educator to meet
those one of those three uh uh
descriptions in in lines seven eight and
nine yes not not not
um that they're right in kindergarten or
um
so this is intended to be a teacher
this is uh
intended to to be uh I suppose a
mentoring program
um but that it allows for the
um
for the district to come up with that
plan and submit that to the department
and and I think the description in lines
five and six
um
I think speak to that about
articulate that that plan has to
articulate what are the pro professional
learning goals and descriptions of the
development activities uh the district
will use to orient a new educator
um
another follow-up yes
um that seems to me that it's a direct
conflict of Title II part A which is
preparing training recruiting high
quality teachers and principals
um
and you have to prove that your
mentoring program has to
meet your District's goals and
objectives in your master plan
and I just worry about those federal
funds as opposed to the state fund
because the federal funds are allocation
so people they need to submit
sort of an application or justification
to be able to use it but they don't
actually need to apply for it it's not
competitive so I'm not sure what this
program would do that's over and above
that because you can have a very robust
mentor and induction program with those
federal funds when I looked up there are
very few every town gets an allocation
but
um except for those I believe that don't
actually have a school building in them
so I just I I'd want to know what does
this do that's different than that or is
it more money to do more and I don't
know why we need more if it already
exists
do you know sure so I think the idea was
we we had heard that there were uh
districts out there that did that
um
that were not necessarily using their
Title II funds for this purpose and the
idea would be as sort of a carrot
that this would be uh something that
they could supplement
um a program and incentivize school
districts to to prioritize this as a um
as a program for their early Educators
and I think at the end of the day so
much of it comes down to you know as you
well know what are we going to spend
whether it's state funds or federal
funds what are we spending them on and
the uh
resources dedicated to those early
educators
can be one of those areas that that
falls falls through the cracks when
you're making difficult decisions about
what to spend your dollars on including
who's your team
so
if you would just clarify for me from
what you just said am I correctly
understanding that
districts might be spending their title
to money on other purposes
and therefore would need what this bill
proposes to do to provide the new
educator mentoring other purposes or
even
that there may be unspent Title II funds
out there that had had they been used
potentially in conjunction with this
could have
been put to use to help the folks that
we're talking about
aren't professional when I received
Title II dollars we usually use those
Pro uh dollars for professional
development in the area for example like
the reading information that represent
cordelli has been bringing forward K
through three or we did it for
mathematics so we did it for some other
area of our curriculum and instruction
I see this bill
here primarily here I think represent
Damon you just said new teacher
mentoring
and so orienting that teacher to what we
do within the system that they're now
going to work within so we may have a
reading program there but we have to get
that teacher up to speed to what we're
doing there but professional development
I see more in regard to the total scope
of what the larger picture for that
school or School District but these
people coming in that we have to orient
and get on task of how we do things here
in town X that's where I see this
mentoring program being of help and
representative Myler I believe you
mentioned that you had a bill coming
forward next session on mentoring yeah
it's being developed okay in development
where do we
where do we go with this seems like
there are uh questions
um about uh
the use of the funds entitled to funds
um
I'd like to have an accounting on that
from the Department in terms of how the
professional to our Title II monies have
been used and what type of uh we did get
a sheet on that as you may recall there
was a balance left over why is it not
being used
um is is a question we should have you
know before we start generating another
pot of money if we have I have the funds
available let's use them
maybe for this area I don't know but we
do need to have an accounting from the
Department on where we stand on that for
I I think that's a good suggestion
um
any further suggestions or should we uh
piggyback this with the future sub
committee meeting also and get that
information from the Department as well
I I think that's the Direction
um that I'm seeing by the nodding the
head so
um we will schedule
um future subcommittee meeting for uh
all four of the ones that we heard today
and
um gather some information in the
meantime both from
um the teacher shortage committee and
from the Department
representative lead are there any
definitions or policy statements which
maybe the school board's Association has
on what is mentoring
is there you know we use mentoring
sometimes here abroadly for so many
different things uh in professional
development is there a consensus amongst
the school districts as far as what they
I guess I mean if there's any school
board policy on it or not you know there
probably isn't
um I see I see you know coming from the
too uh looks like we can uh do some
scheduling work and
um some work and Gathering more
information and uh looking at language
and uh come back uh at some point in
October uh to uh finish this up
right so thank you very much for
everyone in the meantime and uh Morgan
did you have any questions before we uh
break that uh
representative Ladd brought up this
point but just what is the further
distinction between the orientation and
kind of initiation into a new school
district versus the personal development
because I was kind of under the
impression also that personal
development was kind of going above and
beyond and developing a specific set of
skills that teachers are working towards
versus just getting acclimated to a new
um
I think personal development you know
for example as a school principal for
all those years I had the responsibility
for going in and supervising and making
recommendations whether a teacher would
you know at that time be tenured not be
tenured and you do another number of
observations
and you may come out at the end of the
office observation saying
this teacher needs Improvement in this
area
one of the times when I was back here in
the state working over in Romper in
Maine and Robert I recommended that that
teacher go back to the University of
Maine at Farmington and take a course in
language arts and teaching up and that
person did that we helped you know
because it was a recommendation made by
the district we helped with that
um so that was a individual personal uh
need based upon observations done by the
administrator in the school
I don't consider that necessarily
mentoring that's that's just my job to
make sure that we have somebody
qualified at the level we want within
the classroom and you're giving every
Best Shot you can where you see there is
room for improvement
but uh I saw professional development
where on a larger scope of what was good
for the whole as far as our moving
representative Hall did you a little bit
further on the mentoring I do think it's
The Works of the school you've got a new
person coming in your special teachers
are using competency-based grading your
regular teachers are using ABCD and
you're trying to this person's coming in
I need to know the rules of your school
whereas professional development I as a
representative Ladd mentioned I see that
as a whole school initiative we're going
to
okay I can't even think of an initiative
right now we're going to take it on so
the whole school has to be has to learn
about this new program that they're
going to do or the new philosophy or
whatever
um but I think mentoring as an
individual I know in our school the
mentoring program was for those new
teachers that came in and they would
look for a seasoned person you had to be
there let's say five years to be the
mentor and to be paid sometimes you have
them and they're not paid sometimes you
have them and you are paid and then
sometimes people get mad because they
are they Mentor but they don't get paid
because it's just their nature to Mentor
their colleague so it's kind of a I do
thank you very much everybody and
um research
foreign
uh